اكثر من 100 صاروخ اطلقتها روسيا على
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف ومدن اخرى اصابت
عدد من البناء التحتيه الرئيسيه للطاقه
وفق ما اعلن سلاح الجو الاوكراني
امتدت اثار القصف الى خط مهم للكهرباء يمد
بالطاقه الدوله المجاوره مولدوفا والتي
اعلنت عن انقطاعات هائله للكهرباء في
انحاء البلاد بعد قصف روسيا لنظام الطاقه
الاوكراني في الساعه الماضيه انقطع احد
خطوط الطاقه الذي يؤمن انتقال الكهربائي
الى بلادنا وعدد ذلك الى انقطاعات هائله
الكهرباء في انحاء البلاد
دوي الانفجارات كان قد سمع في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف غربا وفي مدينه خار كيف
شمال الشرق البلاد وعقبال ضربات الجويه
انقطعت الكهرباء في العديد من المناطق وفق
مقاله السلطات الاوكرانيه
كما تسبب اوابل الصواريخ الروسيه على
مناطق اوكرانيا باندلاع الحرائق في عده
مباني سكنيه وبتدمير البنيه التحتيه
للطاقه الاخرانيه وفق اعلان الرئيس
الاوكراني بولودي ميرسي
يطلقوا 85 ضربه صاروخيه على اوكرانيا وعلى
مدننا في الغالب على البنيه التحتيه
للطاقه من الواضح هذا ما يريده العدو ولن
يحققه هدفهما ربما لا تنزله هناك ضربته في
المستقبل لذلك اطلب من الجميع توخي الحذر
والبقاء في الملاجيء لفتره من الوقت اعلم
ان الضربات قطعت امدادات الكهرباء عن
العديد من المدن في بلدنا نحن نعمل وسوف
نستعد كل شيء وسوف ننجو من كل شيء
وداع عمده خاركيف السكان للبقاء في
الملاجئ فيما اعلنت شبكه النت بلوكس عن
اضطراب كبير في خدمه الانترنت في اوكرانيا
بعد الهجمات يشار الى ان الضربات
الصاروخيه الروسيه اتت فيما يستمر القتال
شرقا بين القوات الروسيه والاكرانيه كما
اتت بعد ايام على الانسحاب من غير سون
جنوبا وفي خضم عقاد قمه مجموعه العشرين في
اندونيسيا